In these cities, they don't give security or safety in these cities.
They fail spectacularly.
And when it comes to education specific example, the city of Baltimore,
13 public high schools, you want to venture a guess what percentage?
And the 13 schools, not 13 kids, 13 public high schools.
What percentage of kids in those schools? And you don't have to answer.
It's not a trick question.
Well, I'll ballpark it. I'll try just to see.
People are proficient in math and reading.
So for a guy that is governing like a conservative, that's,
that's pretty obvious at this point.
One of the things that we've talked about a couple of times on your show is
what's happening in Portland, in Seattle, in Chicago, in New York,
just the crazy situations of violence and murder and everything else
because of these progressive policies, which by the way, years ago, well, well,
before I knew you, when I would flick on your show,
you were basically the only guy that was talking about the,
the black on black crime in Chicago and nobody and everyone would,
what would they do? They would call you racist for it for even bringing it up.
You'd say, well,
30 black people died this weekend and they would call you the racist for it.
Um, but are you, are you concerned at all that,
that optics wise when Trump then sends in, uh,
the national guard and we get federal troops in these things that this is
playing into the hand that, Oh, well, you see, he's, he's the authoritarian,
he's the guy that wanted to throw all the, all the federal troops into the city.
Well, when Obama said this week,
the federal troops are using tear gas and Bhutan's on peaceful
protestors. That's not true.
And in spite of all the video evidence with Jerry Nadler and saying,
this is a myth actually said it,
or who would ever think that a major party presidential
candidate would say the words, the police are the enemy by what?
And supporting defunding the police. I mean,
Joe Biden has yet to say a good thing about the
99% of police, men and women that protect and serve their cities.
All of them put their lives on the line for all of us every single day.
And so you, you, you ask a great question. Uh,
Donald Trump has not sent in the national guard unless they request it.
He's been begging New York city and Chicago and
Portland and Seattle begging them,
let us help you restore law and order and safety and security.
It can't pursue happiness.
They Reuben without law and order and a safe community.
If you're a one-year-old shot in a park in New York dad and a stroller or an
eight year old little girl killed in Atlanta because her mom made a
wrong turn into the chop zone near where the Wendy's that street had been taken
over a new autonomous zone. Um,
and that little girl in the back of the died after getting shot in the head
or a seven year old beautiful girl in Chicago died on the 4th of July
weekend. Uh, while at her grandmother's house, you know,
playing on the 4th of July or Horus, Lorenzo Anderson,
uh, junior, 19 years old,
and his father that heart-wrenching interview that I had with him. Um,
it killed me. It was my, my kids 18 and 21. Anyway.
So the answer is he's offering now that's separate. And apart from the,
we're talking about a hundred troops that are being sent in to protect federal
property and federal courthouses. That's not only their job,
but their obligation because they would try and to burn them to the ground. Uh,
they're not there to restore law in order to the cities because the mayors
refuse to do it. What w what do all of these cities we're talking about?
New York, Chicago, Portland, Seattle, Los Angeles,
the city of Atlanta, what do they all have in common?
They've all been run by liberal Democrats for decades. Now,
if you believe as I do, and then I get into a lot of this in the book,
which is over your shoulder. Yeah. We're going to get there.
We're going to get there. I promise. We'll get no, but that actually does this.
This does color a lot of this stuff in the book. A lot of it, it,
but if you believe it, our founding document,
our founding document is our declaration, right?
Some people think it's the constitution know the founding document.
What does it say? I can remember it unlike, you know, cookie Jo, uh,
one of my favorite clip had all these truths to be self-evident that all men or
women are created by the thing, you know,
the thing, the thing, God, Joe, God, every the creator of everything. All right.
Oh, that scared me. So, but if you believe in that,
what does that line doubt by our creator means that got rights for all of us.
And I believe those were why mine, my heart, my soul. They come from God.
They don't come from man. They don't come from government.
And that life, Liberty pursuit of happiness.
How do they Reuben? You tell me, how do you proceed to happiness?
If you're living in those cities and you're not safe in a park or your grandma's
backyard on the 4th of July,
or if your mom makes a wrong turn on a city street, uh,
or if your son is in the summer of love zone as mayor Dirk and said,
how do you pursue happiness? If you don't have basic law order safety, security,
how do you pursue happiness in all of these cities?
What is one other commonality?
They all have the worst educational records of most cities in the
world.
We pay more per capita for education than any other
country in the industrialized world. These cities have this income.
We have failed our children. If you look at a ladder, I used to be a contractor,
right? You have the, of the ladder, right? Okay.
You take away that education and I'll give you a little, my BA my background.
I learned Latin.
I went to a seminary in high school and the word education from the Latin
derivative at Duker day to bring forth from within.
So if we believe that God gives you rights.
If education is to bring forth from what is already there from God talents,
he gave you, well, you need safety, security, you need education. So,
okay.
Joe Biden is saying that the government's going to take care of everything you
ever want in your life.
He's going to take care of a guaranteed job at a guaranteed wage and K
through college education and forgive student loans and government guaranteed
vacations and government guaranteed healthy food.
And you're going to have government guaranteed healthcare,
and you're going to have a gun government guaranteed retirement.
And you don't have a worry in the world. I'll get to the psychology of that.
Okay.
What is the track record in these liberal cities that have been run by liberals
for decades, which is what Joe Biden, adopting Bolshevik,
Bernie socialism, and AOC, new green deal. And,
and Bazell bozo as I call them or Rourke and
Bozo's gun confiscation plan. All right. So in these cities,
they don't give security or safety in these cities.
They fail spectacularly.
And when it comes to education specific example, the city of Baltimore,
13 public high schools, you want to venture a guess what percentage?
And the 13 schools, not 13 kids, 13 public high schools.
What percentage of kids in those schools? And you don't have to answer.
It's not a trick question.
I'll I'll ballpark it. I'll try. Just to see.
Believe are proficient in math and reading. Matt, let's start with math.
I mean, I, I'm going to guess I'm going to go obviously crazily low it's.
I'm going to get what's it like 10%, something like that.
Not one child in 13 public high schools,
Baltimore spends they're the third,
highest per capita per student spending in the world,
not one kid in 13 schools. Okay. Here's the ladder.
Why don't you just take a sledgehammer,
rip out all the rungs and beat out most sides of it because you don't have an
education. So they don't provide security, safety, law order.
They don't provide education. All right. What else has government done for us?
If we're going to put all our hate,
we're going to believe Joe Biden and Bernie's socialist utopia and AOC is new
green deal. Okay.
And they're going to take care of every single need we have in life. Okay.
How social security doing Dave Rubin? Because the last I checked,
you're screwed.
I'll probably get something until they means test it because it's headed towards
bankruptcy.
Looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our media playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out the full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.